now 6 23 on your Thursday morning yes it
is Groundhog Day no offense whatsoever
to Punxsutawney Phil back there in
Pennsylvania no groundhogs here in
southern Nevada but there they were just
about an hour ago guys in tuxedos
yanking Phil out of his burrow to look
for his shadow this morning just like
they do on the same day every year he
speaks some kind of groundhog gibberish
he claims that he saw his shadow which
would mean six more weeks of winter but
here in Las Vegas we have a very cool
contest for elementary school students
in Clark County to guess the exact date
and time that they think the desert
tortoise Mojave Max is going to wake
himself up to tell us about spring-like
weather from Clark County desert
conservation the Mojave Max programs
Audrey lot good morning Audrey good
morning Nate how are you the lion mostly
sunny as you know but so tell us where
is Mojave Max right now Mojave Max is in
his Borough right now at the Springs
Preserve there's a 15 acre habitat out
there and he has natural surroundings
it's all his normal habitat but he's in
his Borough right so most desert
tortoises at this time of year they are
technically it's called brewmation but
they're sleeping basically absolutely
yeah it's a little too cold out there
for them they wait till it gets above
60. I know Sherry was mentioning they're
going to be in the 60s next week I don't
know if he'll be out that early but some
consistent 60s he'll come out yeah so we
want to talk about this emergence
contest and it's so cool for me to have
been part of the Mojave Max program for
the past 20 plus years we have this
really cool way of being sort of
informational and fun but also trying to
help students realize they have a role
in protecting the desert tortoises and
making sure that their population
doesn't decline yes exactly and we think
it's important to start at the
elementary school level which is where
you do so much work with us and then we
hope that they take that back home to
their families and then on to Junior
High and high school to their friends
and understanding where we need to be
with them and I can tell you Audrey
having done this as long as they have
and even Sherry we go out to we're out
in the community and people come up to
say I remember when you talked to me
about Mojave Max we have the uh the
mascot in a costume who comes and the
kids really get a kick out of that but
we think we're getting a message across
absolutely in fact the the mascot the
person who's in the mascot costume
remembers Mojave Max coming to their
school when they were in school so we
definitely have a history here and the
children have things that they take away
one of them being don't touch a wild
tortoise if you see one out in the wild
um so there's messaging that definitely
gets across and they take with them and
there are great prizes for the student
that guesses closest to the exact date
and time that Max will wake up and crawl
out of his bro at the Springs Preserve
and you just go to Max's website right
yes mojavemax.com and so what are the
prizes well they get to have a field
trip for their class at the Springs
Preserve they get to meet the real
Mojave Max because he will obviously be
out of burmation because he's emerged
they get laptop they get a laptop the
student who guesses closest and the
teacher of that student also gets a
laptop then they get some other prizes
an annual pass Parks pass they get a
pizza party we throw in some ice cream
at the end and they get a backpack full
of things that will help them enjoy
while they're out exploring in our
desert Audrey lock from the Mojave Max
program thank you so much for being with
us we'll see you at the next School in
just a couple of hours right now